هي من ستحدد هويه المنتصر في هذه الحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا وفقا لصحيفه يوزويك
الامريكيه التي كشفت ان معركه باخم تقترب
من نقطه لا عوده حيث تتصاعد الاشتباكات
حول المدينه قبل هجوم جديد متوقع من روسيا
هذا الربيع لكن لماذا اصبحت المدينه
الصناعيه الصغيره نقطه حرجه في هذه الحرب
ولماذا فشلت روسيا الى الان في السيطره
عليها رغم مشاركه مرتزقه فاجنر فيها يجيب
مسؤولون غربيون لنيوزويك بان الروس يريدون
استخدام باخموت بعد الاستيلاء عليها كنقطه
انطلاق نحو هدفها المتمثل في الاستيلاء
على منطقه دومباس باكملها والامر ذاته
دافع كبير لكيف هي الاخرى ورئيسها الذي
يعتبر الانتصار في بخمه انتصارا لكل
اوكرانيا سيما وانها باتت تشكل رمزا
للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وانها ستكون نقطه
انطلاق هجوم مضاد وفقا لنيوزويك دائما
[موسيقى]